[Music]
anyone who's going to think they want to
pitch
[Music]
hello are
you've got something good as well come
on
whoever's first up come on
all right you guys are up all right good
give me a big hand get my big hands
all right so get the microphone
make sure you're standing there so they
can see the screen
and please go ahead
and hit me with the postcard dn12
yep one a7 uh zed sorry one i said yeah
all right now guys
when when when they come out and pitch
the deal it takes a lot of courage so
please make sure when they're talking
you're listening to them at least give
them the opportunity to hear them out is
that fair enough yes or no so let me
chat in with your friends and talking
about your deal
because this isn't about your deal right
now right now this is about their deal
also how many of you realize that you're
going to learn a lot
from looking at other people's deals yes
or no
all right so we're going to see what
these guys have got to offer and see if
they've missed anything so
let's have a little look is this the
property yeah
all right love it make sure you talk
down the microphone first things first
how much did you budget for the refurb
um i viewed the property i spoke to
latin agent next street got refurbed at
10k at a higher spec
i see this is a problem that you've
actually seen already i bought offering
but they didn't accept it at 43 300.
that was nice
money in money out of two years
all right rent so what's the refurb 10k
all right good pass the mic on what's
the monthly rent the monthly monthly
rent was 600 a month 600 after expenses
215.
600 for this little house in doncaster
after expenses is 215 cash flow
why are the expenses so high
uh that's what the lead agent said when
i spoke to him well you can't just rely
on what the letting agents say you need
to you need to work out what it actually
is going to be because there's a reason
why the lending agents are a letting
agent and not a property millionaire
so for a start i think the rent seems
personally i don't know yeah i don't
know if you'd get 600 for this house
i mean
how how did you get 600 where did you
come up with that figure from did you
just speak to a lane agent and just and
just rely on what they said or did you
do your own research no regarding the
next property on the next street
as well as
let's let's see if you can prove it
i'm going to go on to open rent
what's the postcard bro uh dn12
yeah one a zed
a to zed i like it
all right so
this property oh let's find a like for
like so yours is a three bed ugly ass
mid-terrorist yeah yeah all right three
bed mid terraced
it would be nice if you did a bit of
work on it it probably i think 10 grand
to be fair i think it's very
conservative i'd get this done for four
grand but if you want to call it 10 we
can call it 10.
let's look at other properties similar
so here's a three bed
this ran it for 500.
sorry
all right let's see what else we got
uh another three bird
this is ready for four fifth day
now we can't just rely on one property
say you need to look at multiple this
property rented for five to five and
it's way nicer
so with respect
i'm not saying it's not true that the
property next door okay that maybe that
was the probably next door i don't know
i mean that's crazy 650
650
wow
so it's possible that you get 600
but i think that 600 i mean this render
600 is a two bed i think 600 is possible
but i think it's high end
i think you probably i mean this one oh
jeez to be fair
there is a lot that is rented for six
six fifty
um
let's see this one three bed this one
rented for four four eight
so you're kind of talking but somewhere
between 450 and 650 would probably
depend on the size and the condition
but i'm thinking 600 is probably a
little steep but to be fair
i think 550 is probably very possible
what do you guys think
and if you're going to buy it
for 50 grand is it is it still on the is
it still on the market yeah yeah i just
spoke to her you just spoke to still on
the market going to call me back again
she's gonna call you back yeah i've
already put an offer in a few weeks back
um it said it was gonna sell it hasn't
sold it's fallen through a couple times
um i just rang her and she said she'll
call me back
all right i put my offering up 44 300.
and look at all these in the area
55
545 that's in really bad condition with
no pictures that's a flat
65 80 90. so if you got that for 50
and you put an offer of 54 and they said
no but now they're coming back would you
reckon you get it wrapped up
would you can you get this wrapped up uh
as in donut value
no
as in how much do you think they'll
accept oh 47.48
about 47.48 yeah and then you spend a
few grand on it you're probably going to
push up the value you're going to rent
it out for maybe fifth day
i like it
i like it
i'm gonna make you an offer you've
obviously been speaking to the agent
already
i wanna hear what this man has to say
though
hello
what do you think i think it's good i
think why is it better than everybody
else's
so if we can bring the uh refurb costs
down
yeah i think and put about uh 47 offer
yeah um return on investment we worked
out was around 14.3
depending on the
around you're gonna get a lot more than
that if you get that if you go up to
about 47 and rent that out for 550
that's going to give you an roi of like
24
if you spend a bit of money on it it
might take away from your roi but then
you're pushing the value up and you can
always refinance it later anyway
i like it a lot
and i'm gonna make you guys an offer
the offer is this
obviously you've already viewed it right
so
i get that
you've got the agent calling you back
okay i get that
you've got two options option number one
is i've got in my pocket
i got some money
okay i got some cash
i got here
i got 300 pound
so option number one is i'll just go you
know what guys let me just dump you this
300 pound in your pocket and then you
guys can split it up
and whatever
but then the agent's not going to call
you back the agent's going to call me
back
okay because then i'm just going to take
over i know doncaster really well i got
houses in doncaster man
i know doncaster super well i reckon i
could rent that out for about five to
five and i reckon i've got a team of
builders that will jump in there and do
that roof for four grand
so that's option number one
300 big ones
in your pocket you guys can split it up
have fun buy some dinner whatever option
number two is you can just say now i'm
alright and you can just continue and
you can you can talk to the agent and
you guys can do whatever you want and
we'll just park companies friends
okay now obviously
you guys
are going to need to have
a business discussion about this you're
going to have a meeting and just what
you want to do there's three of you
you've viewed it you kind of found it
you've been working together in this
exercise so is it fair to give them a
chance to have a discussion yes or no
guys
right
however how many of you realize that in
business
when you're talking about deals and
stuff you have to make fast decisions
yes or no
yes or no guys so i'm gonna give you an
opportunity to have a conversation
and when i say go your time is gonna
start
if after if after your business meeting
i go what's going on and you go we
haven't decided yet and you don't give
me an answer
then i'll keep the money and i'll ring
the agent anyway
i'm just playing
but but you need to give me an answer
quickly is that fair okay so you have a
chance to go away and have a business
meeting and then you can get back to me
your business meeting starts now and you
have 15 seconds
[Music]
all right
so guys
if you were them
what would you reckon what did you do
would you take the money or keep the
deal what would you know
how do you take the money
oh well let's find out all right so
we're going to do a drum roll
we're going to do a drum roll and then
and then you're going to answer in a
moment
after a drumroll you're going to tell us
whether you want the money
or whether you want to just keep the
deal and and and i can keep my money all
right so drum roll everybody
what are you gonna do keep the deal
[Music]
hold on hold on
hold on listen to be fair it's a bit of
an awkward situation because he found
the deal so he might be thinking i don't
want to take the money and then i have
to split it three ways
no no but just hear me
here's what i do
if you
what i'll make you one one final offer
is that fair i'll make you one final
offer
get a mic
to me yeah yeah okay here's the offer
you get 300 pounds
they get 100 pounds 500 pounds for the
three of you 15 seconds starts now
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
so question
why did you decide why did you guys
decide to keep the deal
it's a hundred pound it's this is worth
way more than that
[Music]
yeah
yeah i mean hundred pounds come and go
but that deal seems like a good one if
we stick to it
you get a lot more than that
what's up brother
yeah no 100
what but you would have got 500 pounds
between the three i mean that is a
reasonable it's only a 50 grand house
that's one percent of the money just one
percent of the whole value of the house
just bank in your hand cash why did you
make the decision to say you know what
i'm good
because long term
uh if it was to add value to it as well
your 500 pound return on investment is
nothing really no disrespect
all right so listen guys how many of you
realize
that when you know
how to find deals
certainly
you can start saying 500 pounds
no thanks
suddenly you become really really
valuable right and say i
how many of you think that the skills
that you're learning today are going to
be able to help generate you a lot of
money in your life register and say yes
and you know what i think my offer was
reasonable i can't obviously i couldn't
go any higher than 500 but i respect
your decision i think you probably made
the right decision who knows what goes
to happen with the deal they took a risk
they could have just taken a bit of
money now
but instead they said i'd rather have
the potential
to lose everything but i'd rather have
the potential to make a lot of money
down the line and i'd rather learn the
lesson
than just take a quick box so guys mad
respect they show them some love give
them a hand